well let's talk performing i mean the
las vegas residency what a success a
huge success and you know when you think
of other performers uh who have been to
vegas had their own shows celine dion
schneider twain j.lo brittany we're
talking icons you know when this was
presented to you was this like a yes
right away
it was a yes right away and then it was
like uh oh like what does this mean you
know um i feel like there's such a high
standard of entertainment in vegas and i
mean i've been to shows like throughout
the years you know various different
kinds music shows like cirque du soleil
shows um like comedy things like
everything in between um so being able
to
you know it was like okay we like i want
to take this seriously i want everything
to be very much me but i also want it to
be a vegas caliber show so it was a lot
of fun putting things together it was
fun being able to do things like the
aerialists and
we have a few dancers it's not like
super choreographed but they
provide just this different layer and
element um of of entertainment and
being able to interact with them and we
have props that we couldn't necessarily
take on the road with us yeah there's
this big water feature
um everybody's been trying to get me to
get rained on for years and i've always
said no because i'm like i'm not doing
like you know a 50 60 plus show tour
um and just getting soaked every night
and then getting on a on a bus
like i'm just not gonna do it so
um i'll do almost anything but that was
like i'm gonna have to blow dry my hair
it's true
so but this it makes it such a more
controlled environment to be able to do
something like that and it makes it even
more impactful i think that we we
haven't played that card yet yeah and we
get to do that for vegas i love that
yeah you are going on tour which is so
exciting you know at this point in your
career what does life on tour look like
for you and you bring the kids
uh the kids came with me on the last
tour so i started the last tour with a
three month old and that was it was
probably one of the most you know it was
the hardest thing that i've i've ever
done um
but by the end of it i'm like girl you
can do anything um so i felt so
accomplished um you know our our lives
together all of us on the bus like we we
made it and we we thrived um but this
time they're not coming with me
they may they may come out for like uh
weekend stuff things like that um if
there's different holiday you know
they'll come or if we're nearby i feel
like we roll through nashville a lot
yeah um so i i will definitely you know
get to see plenty of them get to be mom
you know plenty um
but my oldest is is in school
definitely you know feel like that's a
huge priority and um you know want his
want both of their lives to just be as
normal as possible um
and that's that's a priority for us yeah
no that's that's being a good mom that's
looking out for your kids um you know
obviously i feel very blessed i have to
toot my my husband's horn a little bit
yeah you know he's got it he's got it on
lock when i'm gone you know he's i never
have to like
worry and you know that you know the
lunches aren't getting packed and the
laundry's not getting done and that kind
of stuff like he's he's got it and he
um you know supports supports me in and
what i do and
i don't i i kind of wish they missed me
a little bit when i'm gone
that's a good that's a good thing
it is it's so nice that you can you know
trust your husband so much like that i
can't say that about my dad if my mom
left us with him so that's lovely well
just one parent in general is you know
is is it's hard yeah it is he's yeah
he's got it well when you're on tour
obviously staying fit is so important
important when it comes to performing
and i have to tell you we're obsessed
with you and your fitness your legs are
fitness goals i just need to know the
secret
uh nothing complicated to be honest
a lot of basic moves a lot of basic
equipment um i do have an app for that
we we created an app called fit52
and
it's it's all things you pick your
your level of fitness you pick your
equipment that you have you don't need a
giant gym
um we started working on this before
most the gyms got shut down and
had no idea that people were gonna need
a way to work out at home with minimal
equipment and we we're like we
we got you um
so we we do that my husband does that a
lot too um we do a lot of 52 and
i love to run um i like to work on my
cardio because it means a lot when i'm
singing but lots of squats lots of
lunges
nothing nothing super crazy
you